on a cold winter day in denver the
morning temperature was 7 degrees
fahrenheit by noon it had fallen 9
degrees and by 5 pm that afternoon it
fell another 6 degrees
what was the temperature at five pm so
let's draw a number line here just to
visualize what's going on
so let's
this is zero or since we're talking
about temperature we could say it's zero
degrees fahrenheit we have one two three
four
five six seven so in the morning the
temperature was seven degrees fahrenheit
that's right over here seven degrees
seven degrees fahrenheit by noon it had
fallen nine degrees so we're going to
subtract 9 degrees from the 7 degrees
so it's going to be 7
minus 9. let me do this way
it had fallen 9 degrees so we're going
to subtract 9 degrees and then by 5 pm
it fall fell another 6 degrees
it fell another 6 degrees so the
expression for our temperature at 5 pm
is the 7 degrees minus 9 minus another
6. on the number line when you subtract
something you're really just moving to
the left so you start at 7 we're going
to move 9 to the left so one way to
think about it is if you move 7 to the
left you're going to get back to 7 and
you're going to have to do 2 more to get
to 9. so this we're going to get to
negative 2
degrees
so this will get us to negative 2
degrees and you can verify that we're
moving 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 to the left
we have moved nine to the left let me so
that the length of that arrow is nine
obviously the length of this arrow right
over here is
seven another way to think about this be
this is negative two degrees is you
could say the length of the temperature
the absolute value of the temperature is
going to be in the negative direction at
noon is going to be the difference of
this orange arrow and this yellow arrow
the difference in their lengths and so
you could say that this would be the
negative because you know that you're
subtracting a larger number from a
smaller number it's the negative of the
larger
of nine
minus seven
nine minus 7 and this will also this
will also give you negative 2 either way
so so far this part right here evaluated
to negative 2 and then we're going to
subtract another 6. so it's going to be
negative 2
minus
6. so we're going to move another 6 to
the left
so we're going to move another 6 to the
left
and so we're going to go negative 2
negative 3 negative 4 negative 5
negative 6 negative 7 negative 8. that
is 1 2 3 4 5 6
spots to the left now we don't want to
always have to draw number lines and
things like that and just to think about
it in a way that you wouldn't have to
count like i just did if i had negative
2
if i had negative 2 minus 6 you could
say look i'm already starting 2 to the
left of 0 and i'm going to go 6 more to
the left of 0 so i'm definitely going to
be left of 0 and i'm going to be 8 to
the left of 0. start 2 to the left of 0
and i'm going to go 6 more to the left
or you could view this as the negative
of the absolute value of 2 which is 2
plus the absolute value of 6. and that's
because on in both we were already at
the left and we moved even more in the
negative direction can we do this and
this helps solve this makes the
computation maybe a little bit easier or
maybe it doesn't whatever i guess floats
your boat anyway hopefully you found
that helpful so 7 minus 9 minus 6 is
negative eight
is equal to
is equal to
negative
negative eight